حياكم الله مشاهدينا ضيفنا اليوم هو وزير
خارجيه اسبانيا حسي مانويل البارس اهلا
وسهلا بك في الجزيره اهلا بك في الدوحه
بخصوص هذه الحرب التي تدور في
غزه بدا موقفكم مختلفا ومتقدما منذ
البدايه على باقي الدول
الغربيه ما هو تقديركم
ورؤيتكم للخروج من هذه
الحرب
نحن كنا نتحدث وبشكل واضح تماما منذ
البدايه في السابع من
اكتوبر نحن ادنا الهجوم الارهابي على
اسرائيل وقلنا ان اسرائيل لديها الحق في
الدفاع نفسها ضد هذا الهجوم الارهابي
لكننا في الوقت عينه نقول انه في اي رد
عليك ان تقرن ردك باحترام القانون
الانساني الدولي نحن نطالب بوقف دائم
وفوري لاطلاق النار لان
27000 من الفلسطينيين من المدنيين قتلوا
وهذا غير مقبول ونحن نطالب ايضا بالغا
الانسانيه ان تدخل الى غزه من دون شروط
وفورا فيجب ان نوفر هذا الدعم الانساني
لهذا السبب نحن نستمر في دعمنا للاونروا
يوم امس قلت امام البرلمان اننا
سنزيد بنسبه
3.5 مليون يورو لاصبح 22 مليون دولار
مساهمه يورو عفوا مساهمتنا لان المزيد من
الفلسطينيين يحتاجون الى هذا الدعم علينا
ان نفكر على المدى البعيد ونريد ان تكون
هذا هل هذا العنف وهذه الحرب هي الاخيره
في الشرق الاوسط لهذا السبب اقترحنا مؤتمر
سلام من شانه ان يتبنى حل الدولتين
بالنسبه للشعب الفلسطيني يجب ان يكون هناك
امل امل حقيقي بدوله فلسطينيه قابله
للحياه تضم الضفه الغربيه وغزه تحت سلطه
واحده مرتبطه بممر وان يكون
عاصمتها القدس الشرقيه وتعيش بسلام مع
اسرائيل سيد الوزير اثرت نقاط عديده لناخذ
خطوه خطوه واحده واحده فيما يتعلق
بالموضوع
الانساني الوضع في غزه كارثي بكل الابعاد
حتى بعد اسابيع من انعقاد وقرارات محكمه
العدل
الدوليه هذه المناشدات
والمطالب التي قدمتموها في اسبانيا
وقدمتها دول اخرى ما زالت المساعدات تدخل
بالقطاره للقطاع ما الذي يمكن ان تفعلوه
لتسريع
هذا
نعم انا اتفق معك
تماما لا يوجد هناك معونات انسانيه كافيه
تصل الى غزه وهذا امر غير مقبول لان كل
فلسطيني كل فرد فلسطين يجب ان يحصل بحريه
على الطعام والماء والدواء والمواد
الغذائيه كل هذا يجب ان تضمن لان هذه هي
مستلزمات الحياه مدنيين اسبانيا مستعده
مستعده لكي تذهب من يوم غد اذا كانت شروط
السلام توفره لهذا السبب
نحن نتعاون مع الشعب الفلسطيني منذ بدايه
هذه الازمه لهذا السبب نقول ان الانرو في
غزه وخارج غزه الانرو ايضا لها وجود ونشاط
في الاردن في الضفه الغربيه في لبنان وفي
اماكن اخرى كثيره وهم
يلعبون دورا كبيرا بطاقم انساني كبير في
حالات الطوارئ لهذا السبب نحن نطالب فورا
بوصول الاغاثه فورا تحدثت عن محكمه العدل
الدوليه
بالطبع اسبانيا تؤيد قراراتها وهناك
تدابير معينه اصدرتها المحكمه ونحن ندعو
كل الاطراف جميع الاطراف ان يمتثلوا لها
ويطبقها واحد هذه الامور هو المساعدات
الانسانيه للذهاب غدا ما الذي
يمنعكم بالطبع الحرب الوضع الامني لا
نستطيع ان نبعث ب طواقمنا الانسانيه فنحن
نرى حتى مقر قياده الامم المتحده في غزه
يتعرض للقصف هذا يجب ان يتوقف ايضا هناك
فرق بين اهداف ارهابيه وبين السكان
المدنيين اماكن الصلاه والعباده اماكن
الامم المتحده المدارس المستشفيات كلها
يجب ان تحظى بحمايه شامله من
القصف كان هناك استياء اسرائيلي بعد ان
ظهر رئيس الوزراء في معبر رفح منددا بعدم
دخول المساعدات الانسانيه
الى القطاع كيف تعاملتم مع رده الفعل هذه
وتداعياتها انا قلت علنا
وامام
التلفزيون الاسباني بعد دقائق مما سمعته
من كلام الاسرائيليين حول رئيس الوزراء
طبعا نحن رفضنا ذلك ونقول نفس الشيء منذ
السابع من اكتوبر وسنستمر في
في رفع صوتنا ول نخفض صوتنا فيما يتعلق
بال سكان المدينين فلسطينيين اسبانيا تريد
السلام السلام للشعب الفلسطيني والسلام
للشعب الاسرائيلي ونريد دوله فلسطينيه
حقيقيه قابله للحياه وتتعايش في امن مع
دوله اسرائيل لهذا السبب نحن بالطبع
نرفض ما قال
الحكومه الاسرائيليه نحن نريد افضل علاقات
مع دوله اسرائيل لان الشعب الاسرائيلي هم
اصدقاء للشعب الاسباني كما هو الحال مع
الشعب الفلسطيني لكننا لن نغير ما نقوله
ولن نخفض صوتنا دفاعا عن الفلسطينيه الان
في
غزه احد الاسباب الوضع الامني على ما هو
عليه احد الاسباب التي تحول دون وصولك
وادخال المساعدات من طرفي الى القطاع هو
السلاح الذي يصل لاسرائيل والذي يمكنها من
استمرار هذه الحرب هناك عده منظمات حقوقيه
اسبانيه تناشد الحكومه الاسبانيه بوقف بيع
السلاح لاسرائيل
فورا وفي الواقع هناك سابقه اليوم
فقط بلجيكا احدى ولاياتها لونيا
اوقفت التراخيص التي تمنح لبيع الاسلحه
لاسرائيل
هل يمكن ان نتوقع خطوه مماثله من
اسبانيا نحن نفعل ذلك من الان ومنذ السابع
من اكتوبر اوقفنا كل التراخيص لتصدير
السلاح الى
اسرائيل في الشرق الاوسط اخر ما يحتاجه
الناس هو السلاح ما نتاج هو محاولات وقف
هذا العنف الذي ينتشر في كل مكان ادخال
السلاح للمنطقه هو عكس ذلك ما نحتاجه هو
الطعام مصادر الطاقه الماء الدواء لكن فوق
كل هذا نحتاج الى السلام ولم يعد منذ
السابع من اكتوبر اي عمليه تصدير للسلاح
من اسبانيا الى اسرائيل انتم حاليا في
الدوحه هل هناك تعاون بينكم وبين الدوحه
بخصوص هذه الحرب وباي
اتجاه واحده من الاسباب او ربما السبب
الرئيسي لزيارتي الان هو
ان نحشد قوانا الى بلد مهم مثل قطر وانا
اليوم عندما التقيت الامير والتقيت رئيس
الوزراء وزير الخارجيه ان اثمن الوره قطر
في الوساطه فهي ليست المره الاولى راينا
ذلك في افغانستان ولعبت قطر دورا مهما
مكنت اسبانيا من ايصال المتعاونين الافغان
معنا الى اسبانيا نحن نفعل ذلك الان مع
غزه ونحن ايضا نطالب بعقد مؤتمر للسلام
وجهود
الوساطه نحن والقطريون نطالب بالامر نفسه
وقف اطلاق النار فوري والسماح بالمساعدات
الانسانيه واطلاق صراح الرهائن وهو امر
مهم للغايه وايضا دوله فلسطينيه هذا هو
الحل الحقيقي نعم اثرت هذه النقطه اكثر من
مره ضروره الاعتراف بدوله فلسطينيه وفي
الواقع رئيس الحكومه الاسبانيه قال انه
يجب ان يتم هذا خلال هذه الولايه
التشريعيه للحكومه هل هناك تاريخ معين
ترونه لا يوجد تاريخ محدد ما نود القيام
به هو ان مؤتمر السلام هذا سياتي
بالفلسطيني
والاسرائيليين واي ما يتفقون عليه
بالتفاوض كما فعلوا عده مرات في التاريخ
في مدريد وفي اوصله اي ما يتفقون عليه نحن
سنعترف به لكن لم يكن هذا مكنا اسبانيا
دوله ذات سياده سوف نرفع صوتنا دفاعا عن
الدوله الفلسطينيه وما قاله رئيسنا هو ان
هذا جدل ونقاش سيتم داخل اروقه البرلمان
الاسباني الي الى اي حد هناك توافق اوروبي
بهذا الخصوص هل تتطلع ربما اسبانيا للعب
دور قيادي بهذا الاتجاه ل جعله واقعا
قابلا للتنفيذ في المدى
القصير نحن نلعب هذا الدور القيادي
والريادي وحل الدولتين حل قبلته البلدان
السبعه وال المضويه تحت الاتحاد الاوروبي
اضافه الى
ذلك نحن في البرلمان الاوروبي نسعى وفي
برلماننا نسعى ونسعى مع عدد من الشرك
الاوروبيين
لتحصيل الاعتراف الدوله الفلسطينيه كل ما
نقوم به له هدف واحد وهو احلال السلام
والاستقرار للجميع في الشرق الاوسط ارد
فقط ان اسالك عن 600 جندي اسباني موجودين
طبعا ضمن المهمه الاماميه في لبنان كيف
تنظرون الى الاوضاع في هذه الجبهه تحديدا
وامكانيه
تصعيدها قب من الان زرت لبنان ثم زرت
العراق بعد ذلك
والتقيت
بالوحده الاسبانيه وهي اكبر وحده عدد عددا
تحت رايه الامم المتحده ومن يقود اليونيفل
هو الجنرال اسباني وقد اتيحت الفرصه لي
للحديث معه وما قاهه لي مقلق للغايه
بالنسبه لي فقد قيل لي
انهم يرون تكرار القصف المتبادل بين
الطرفين وهذا كان احد اسباب زيارتي الى
لبنان والى العراق فنحن لا نريد لهذا
العنف ان ينتشر لو ان لبنان دخلت الحرب
كما كان الحال في الماضي قبل نحو عقدين
هذه ستكون كارثه حقيقيه والازمه التي
موجوده الان في غزه ستس علينا ان نفعل ما
نستطيع وهذا امر بحثنا مع السلطات القطريه
اليوم علينا ان نفعل ما نستطيع للحيلوله
دون حدوث ذلك واسبانيا مستعده لتقديم
الدعم
والمساعده ليس فقط تحت راه الامم المتحده
فقد ضاعفنا ثلاث مرات مساهمتنا هناك فيما
يتعلق بما يجري في البحر الاحمر ثمه حديث
عن انزعاج اسباني من تصريحات وزير الدفاع
الامريكي لويد اوستن عن المشاركه
الاسبانيه في المهمه
العسكريه السؤال الى اي حد تتعرضون لضغوط
امريكيه في هذا
الخصوص كلا ابدا على الاطلاق الولات
المتحده هي حليف طبيعي للاتحاد الاوروبي
لاسبانيا نحن سويه في النيتو وفي بلدان
اخرى مثل العراق حيث زرت القوات الاسبانيه
هناك
تعلم اهميه البحر الاحمر وبالطبع
نحن ندعم مبدا حريه الملاحه في عالي
البحار اذا الهجمات
الحوثيه ضد السفن الامريكي هذا امر يجب ان
يتوقف نحن لا نقبله لكن اسبانيا تدعم مهمه
اوروبيه هذا ما نبحثه الان في بروكسل وسوف
ندعم انشاء بعثه
امن الاوروبيه لحمايه السفن الامريكيه في
البحر الاحمر لن نشارك
بسفن لكن من المهم ان نضمن احترام هذا
المبدا في القانون الدولي وهو حريه
الملاحه في عالي البحار وسوف بالطبع نسمح
بحدوث مهمه اوروبيه بهذا الصدد دعني اختم
سياده الوزير
بؤال يتعلق بالرؤيه
الاسبانيه للحل والاستقرار في المنطقه
وكيف تغيرت عما كانت عليه قبل السابع من
اكتوبر بعد هذه
الحرب اعتقد ان السابع من اكتوبر قد
اعطانا درجه جديده من الوعي كلنا يجب ان
نقر باننا كلنا كنا ننسى الحل كا اسسي
الدوله الفلسطينيه مستقبل الشعب الفلسطيني
وكنا نعتبر ان حاله الاستقرار ستبقى لكن
السابع من اكتوبر جعلنا ندرك انه من دون
افق امل وحل حقيقي للشعب الفلسطيني لن نرى
السلام والاستقلال في والاستقرار عفوا في
المنطقه وان فكره حل الدولتين ان لم
تتحقق اهميه تحقيقها الان اصبحت اكثر من
اي وقت مضى اذا من خضم هذه الكارثه
الانسانيه ومن خضم مقتل كل هذا العدد من
الناس الابرياء قد ينبثق شيء جديد سلام
للمنطقه وتاكدوا من ان اسبانيا ستكون الى
جانب اولئك الذين يريدون احلال السلام في
الشرق الاوسط حسو البارس وزير خارجيه
اسبانيا شكرا على وجودك
معنا